with the stock market in free fall the
trump administration floats bailouts
bernie struggles for traction in final
primaries and rashida talib shows her
anti-semitism yet again
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a vpn
yet
visit expressvpn.com
ben okay so let's begin with the
international news about coronavirus the
market seemed to have recovered a little
bit
this morning they began up a little bit
so it seems like the market has found
its new bottom but we think that every
day or so the markets are really up and
down
we've seen the markets climb three
percent down four percent up five
percent down seven percent
last yesterday the markets dropped about
eight percent which was correction
market correction territory
they've been down overall from their
highs about 29
000 which was just a couple of weeks ago
they are now hovering around 24 000
probably they will do so unless there's
another major shock in terms of the news
let's look at the international news
about coronavirus now the reason i start
with the international news
is because i hear a lot from people who
are in conservative media
in the conservative world that the media
in the united states are blowing this
thing way out of proportion in order to
target trump and domestically there's
some truth to that domestically there's
no question that the media would love to
see trump fall flat on his face
throughout this entire process that they
can use it
as a club to wield against trump and
because the fact is this trump's chaotic
style his chaotic management style the
fact that he sounds awful a lot
in most areas of american life that has
very little impact i think that most
americans have sort of priced
the chaotic side of trump in and the
fact that trump says a lot of stuff on
twitter
most americans like okay whatever as
long as my 401k is fine who cares as
long as we're doing the right things on
foreign policy let him spout whatever he
wants on twitter i'm not even on twitter
i've got a life
i'm not following around the president's
commentary day by day
when it comes to things like crisis
response where people look directly to
government
for handling and particularly in a
situation like this where we are talking
about pretty significant restrictions
on everyday life in the united states
people tend to look to the president
for that sort of stuff and so the media
have a new lease on an argument they've
been using about trump for a while here
which is that his chaotic management
style and in fact his chaotic rhetoric
are really bad overall and have some
really significant impacts now
in the end his rhetoric probably going
to matter very much at all in the end
just like every other aspect of american
government what the government does
matters a lot more than what the head of
the government says and
the president of the united states says
now again i'm not
somebody who underestimates what the
president says i think that half the job
is what the president says
but again because people don't take
trump literally as much as they take him
sort of seriously and selena zito's
famous formulation
in the end the policy is going to be
what the policy is going to be and so
people who are informed are not
listening to trump on coronavirus
they're instead listening to
his people they're listening to mike
pence they're listening to dr anthony
fauci
from the national institute for allergy
and infectious diseases that are
listening to the us surgeon general
they're listening to people actually
know what they're talking about so the
american public are already starting to
price in
trump's commentary and ignore trump's
commentary throughout the media
would like you to focus on trump's
commentary specifically because trump
has a habit in these particular
situations of stepping on regs now
all of this is true about the media and
the media would love to see trump fail
but when people suggest
that the coronavirus itself is being
wildly blown out of proportion
in the united states what they are
missing is that it's pretty bad abroad
i mean the fact is that the italian
government is not doing this to hurt
trump
the israeli government is not shutting
down travel in order to hurt trump
the chinese government isn't welding
people in their houses in order to hurt
trump and so
to understand sort of the balance
between what the media are doing and yes
they have
two mandates here one is to hurt trump
and the other is a much more important
mandate obviously and that is to provide
people with news of what's going around
the world
you have to understand that this isn't
completely made up it's not completely
exaggerated
and to order in order to understand that
you really do have to understand the
statistics statistical
sort of inability to understand things
complete illiteracy with regard to
statistics
is a very bad thing in the media people
don't understand how basic statistics
work
and and so people will say things like
okay only 3 000 people have died so far
from coronavirus so why exactly are we
paying so much attention to it
obviously swine flu from april 2009 to
august 2010 killed about 9 000 people in
the united states alone
globally coronavirus has only killed 3
500 people so why are we all panicked at
this point
okay the reason that everybody is taking
this stuff really seriously
is because government action in places
like south korea in places like china
has indeed tamped down the transmission
of coronavirus and to understand how
important that is you have to understand
that covet 19 is significantly more
transmissible
than other diseases like sars or mirrors
have been in the past
so it is much more deadly than swine flu
it is less transmissible
than swine flu but that's you know
we don't actually know that because so
many cases have not been reported yet
now the good news is i think when all
this is said and done covet 19
is going to be a multiple of the flu but
it is not going to be anywhere in the
range of this
of the the spanish influenza for example
right now here's here's what is being
reported
by business insider in terms of the
number of global cases as of march 6
and the estimated mortality rate now
remember the estimated mortality rate is
probably
too high right now in terms of what
people are talking about because the
number of actual diagnosed cases
is absolutely unclear testing kits have
not been available throughout the united
states they're only a million testing
kits available right now
we don't even know where those are
deployed abroad not everybody has been
tested either
but they're about a hundred thousand
cases that have been diagnosed all over
the world
there's about a 3.4 mortality rate so
about 3 400 people are dead
and the the swine flu which was from
april 2009 to august 2010
some 700 million people to 1. 1.4
billion people
were estimated to have come down with
swine flu but the death rate
in swine flu was point zero two percent
so the the coven 19 virus is about 17
times more deadly
than the swine flu is according to these
stats now again
those stats are are not really
as as solid as we would like them to be
because we don't actually know at this
point
how much how many cases have actually
been diagnosed of
covid 17 we don't know the answer to
that
and and when you compare it to other
diseases this is why people are worried
about covenant 19. cyrus has about a 10
mortality rate but there were only 8
000 cases globally mirrors had a 34
mortality rate but they're only about
2500 cases globally there are hundreds
of thousands of caves
cases presumably of covid 19. so
it's very difficult to tell at this
point what the death rates are but this
is why people are worried by the way
it's not 17 times as deadly according to
those statistics actually 170
170 times more deadly than the swine flu
if we were to have a 3.4
death rate from coronavirus okay so with
all that said
that is why people are looking to the
government to take pretty significant
measures and that's why the government
has been taking significant measures
in countries abroad they took
significant measures in china after
allowing this thing to to flow freely
out of wuhan for a month and a half
they finally took some pretty
significant measures and now you're
starting to see
the number of coronavirus diagnoses
going down
the same thing happened in south korea
and you're starting to see the number of
coronavirus cases go down that's a good
sign
it's a really good sign it means that if
there is actual social distancing
if people do not go to major public
sporting events for
even a little while if you are able to
thin
people out in terms of sort of
aggregating people in small spaces then
you're able to lower the number of
diagnoses
and hopefully people then outlive their
transmission period and the thing
basically
goes away and becomes a seasonal virus
once a year and by that point we
hopefully hopefully have a vaccine that
is sort of best-case scenario
right now but that's why people are
worried and that's why to suggest that
nothing important is going on the media
is making this all up in terms of the
threat level this is basically just like
the flu it is not just like the flu
it is significantly more deadly than the
flu by best available estimates it's a
minimum of seven times more deadly than
the flu and we don't know quite how
transmissible
it is yet and we also don't know exactly
how many people
have it now as i say all these stats
could be totally wrong also i mean it
could be there are a lot more people who
have
coronavirus and have not been diagnosed
with it and it could be that
then by percentage the number of people
dying is a lot lower so it does look
more like the flu but
because there's this broad range we
don't actually know we do know that it's
targeting older people we do know that
it is not targeting
younger people and i believe there have
been no cases
that i'm aware of of people under the
age of nine who have died from
coronavirus which is a good sign
people disproportionately elderly people
are being hurt by all this we'll get you
more on coronavirus in just one second
first
let us talk about making your business
more efficient how do you make your
business more efficient well you don't
spend tons of money on legal it is so
easy to rack up giant legal bills i know
i've done it in the past
but why would you do that when you can
have the legal resources of legalzoom
available to you
right now over the past 19 years
legalzoom has helped more than two
million americans start their businesses
by incorporating forming an llc
and more you have to be a lawyer to use
legalzoom i've been using legalzoom for
years long before they're an advertiser
on the program they make things like
wills and trusts incredibly easy even
after your business is set up
legalzoom can still help you with things
like lease agreements changing tax laws
and reviewing contracts
all of those play a part in running your
own business and again legalzoom can
save you a
ton of money instead of paying an hourly
rate to a high-priced lawyer these are
precisely the kinds of costly hurdles
that can take time away from growing
your business
don't let that happen legalzoom's
network of independence attorneys and
tax professionals can provide advice to
address these things and more
you'll never get charged by the hour
since legal zoom again is not a law firm
go to legalzoom.com today
enter promo code ben in the box at
checkout for special savings that is
legalzoom.com
promo code ben legalzoom where life
meets legal go check them out
right now legalzoom.com promo code ben
okay so as i say the reason i'm looking
at sort of the measures that have been
taken abroad
is because those at least have nothing
to do with trump that's a good control
group
for exactly how worried people are
across the world
taking out the trump factor and the
media trying to exacerbate the situation
in the united states in terms of panic
in the united states
so what exactly is happening while there
is a massive severe travel limit imposed
across the entire country of italy
announced on monday by prime minister
giuseppe conte
in a prime time news conference
according to the new york times with the
announcement that cyprus had confirmed
to infections every country in the eu
has now reported cases of the virus but
the approaches to slowing the spread
very widely
from nation to nation more than 114 000
cases of infection have now been
reported globally about 4
000 people dead but fear and anxiety are
outpacing the immediate danger
the speed with which the virus is
spreading has left public health
officials rushing to catch up there have
been over 7 500 diagnosed cases in south
korea but we're starting to see that
decline now
in wuhan province we're starting to see
this decline in italy there have been
well over 9 000 cases diagnosed in iran
there have been 71
7 100 cases diagnosed
in many of those countries basically all
non-essential travel has been banned
we've seen internationally a lot of
school closing spain has about 1600
cases they announced that schools in the
madrid area would be closed adding 1.2
million children to the 300 million
whose education has already been
disrupted
worldwide the saint patrick's day parade
in dublin was cancelled
the global accounts of at least 114 000
cases also includes more than 64
000 people who have recovered so it is
important to recognize that the vast
number of people who are actually coming
down with coronavirus
are recovering from all of this
president xi jinping actually
traveled to wuhan but we're not going to
know
until all of the how bad this is until
the travel restrictions are eventually
lifted france and spain are seeing the
biggest surge in new infections each is
now confirming over 1600 infections
germany
is not far behind they have 1200
infections the czech republic
has about 41 cases but announced that
all schools aside from universities
would close
starting on wednesday that is according
to prime minister
andres andres babis the spanish
government
closed all education centers in madrid
from nursery schools to university
in poland schools in poznan a city in
the west of the country were ordered
closed after a single case of infection
was discovered austria barred travelers
from italy without a health certificate
switzerland is considering
a similar measure serbia has temporarily
barred travelers from the worst affected
places now none of this is permanent
obviously
what we are what we are hoping is that
if people basically stay where they are
and then they self quarantine then after
14 days
they are either recovered or we know
what they have and then we can and then
we can move them into a hospital where
they actually
require the care what you don't want is
people circulating around and passing
the disease
faster than we know how to stop any of
this so
the united states we've seen similar
measures being taken on sort of a
voluntary basis you're seeing the
government take a very heavy role
in places like israel and israel they've
now said that anyone who enters the
country has to self-quarantine for a
minimum of 14 days
foreign nationals who are unable to
demonstrate to israeli border
authorities that they will be able to
self-quarantine for two weeks will not
actually be able to enter the country so
if you had a seven day
trip planned to israel they'll just
reject you at the border they won't
allow you to come into the country
right now everybody is basically just
saying lock down sit down
stay where you are in the united states
we've seen some major universities who
are canceling classes for the rest of
the semester at least
in person classes you're starting to see
people
do online education which by the way
would be a good answer to a lot of our
problems
in the united states generally on
tuesday the fulton county school system
which covers the suburbs of atlanta
became the largest u.s school district
to close
after one employee tested positive for
the virus schools in snohomish county
near the center of the crisis in
washington state
were also closed after an employee in
the transportation department
tested positive amherst college has
canceled classes harvard college
has urged people not to return from
campus after spring break
officials in santa clara county
escalated their recommendations to limit
mass gatherings
and ordered a mandatory mandatory ban
starting wednesday
at midnight so one of the things that
the people are worried about with
regards to the trump administration is
again there are no set rules
and and you are hearing stories about
people who come down
with a cough or they come down with a
fever and they don't know what to do
because the instructions are not clear
are they supposed to go to a hospital or
are they supposed to stay home now the
answer is if you are young you are
basically supposed to stay home
if you are elderly then you should
probably think about going to a hospital
because this is disproportionately
affecting elderly people
the cdc is now recommending that if you
are over 60 years old you should stock
up on supplies and you should avoid
crowds
nancy massonia is director of the cdc's
national center for immunization and
respiratory disease
and she says that as the trajectory of
the outbreak continues many people in
the us will at some point in time this
year or next be exposed to this virus
and there's a good chance many will
become sick the reason to stock up now
is to kind of stick close to home
missonia said global data from japan and
south korea
showed that people younger than 60
generally have better outcomes if they
catch the virus but people older than 60
are higher risk for serious illness
especially if they have an underlying
health condition like diabetes heart
disease or lung disease
young people with underlying health
problems are also at risk obviously so
one of the reasons why you shouldn't
have giant gatherings
presumably is that even if you are a
young person you come down with it
you're now a carrier so if you've got a
grandpa or grandma
and then you see grandpa or grandma at a
family event next week you could still
transmit the virus
to them this is why
happily for me we are now recommending
anti-social behavior so that
as somebody who's not a big event guy uh
that i i don't think that uh you know i
i benefit from from the fact that now
everyone will act like me and not want
to hang out with human beings so that
that's a good thing but other than that
obviously this is crimping a lot of
people's style and it's having some
pretty
significant economic impacts we'll get
to more of this in
just one second first let us talk about
how you're going to look better this
year you're making a first impression
on somebody well one of the big things
that you want to make sure
is there is a nice smile you don't want
your teeth looking every which way you
don't want to look like jafar
in that scene beneath the castle where
he is dressed up as an old man his teeth
are going all the wrong way it's all
very weird you don't want that what you
want is a beautiful disney smile
and the way to get that is you go check
out kanzad unlike braces candid clear
aligners are comfortable removable and
totally invisible you can transform your
smile without anyone noticing a thing
plus you never have to set foot in a
doctor's office or a waiting room your
treatment is prescribed and monitored
remotely by a licensed orthodontist with
other remote clear aligner options
you may never hear from a doctor
candidate only works with experienced
orthodontists only experts in tooth
movement never general dentist with
candid
your treatment will be remotely
monitored by that same orthodontist
throughout so you'll never have to
wonder how everything is going
with canada the average treatment length
is just six months you'll start seeing
results way before then
learn more about candidates process get
a complimentary 3d scan of your teeth at
a candid studio near you
it is the simplest freest way to get
started again whether it's business or
your personal life
you want your smile to look great candid
can make this happen i've been using
candidate myself and man
i am gorgeous all right you ready to
take the first step towards straighter
teeth for a limited time get started
with 75 bucks off by using code shapiro
at candidco.com
shapiro that is shapiro use code shapiro
for 75 bucks off
candidco.com shapiro use code shapiro
okay so we are we are hearing sort of
all of these conflicting messages people
are indeed self-quarantining mark
meadows the new chief of staff for
president trump is self-quarantining
because he met
the individual who apparently had
coronavirus at cpac
he is not the only one that a bunch of
people have been self-quarantining
obviously republican senators ted cruz
self-quarantine he saw paul gosar from
arizona
self quarantine and then talk about how
he would rather die in battle than die
of the flu which is a real weird move
the they're they're washington post
political and daily beast reporters who
are else all self-quarantining after
attending
cpac everybody is saying sort of
abundance of caution
people are staying home politico's put
out a memo saying we understand this
news may be jarring
it's important to recognize this was a
large conference the risk of
transmission for employees
who are not in close contact with the
infected individual is incredibly low
and all of that is true and it's
important to hear from
sort of the people who know what they're
talking about this is why don't rely on
politicians
don't even rely on talk show hosts like
me really talk to people who know what
they are talking about that would be
presumably dr anthony fauci it would be
the u.s surgeon general so here's the
surgeon general yesterday explaining
that young people
are more likely to die of the flu than
coronavirus so if you're young you don't
really have to worry about coronavirus
killing you the only thing that we're
really worried about is that you become
a carrier or a transmitter of
coronavirus and then you carry it to an
older person here's the u.s surgeon
general
if you are a child or young adult you
are much more
you're more likely to die from the flu
if you get it than you are to die from
coronavirus so there is something about
being young
that is protective we want people to be
reassured
by that we want people to know that we
are really focusing in
on those those groups that are at
highest risk
for complications and helping them
understand how to be safe right and
this is it's really interesting to see
sort of how the societal ramifications
of coronavirus go
and we'll get to the economic
ramifications in just a second but in
terms of some of the social
ramifications
one of the big things that has cropped
up here is that nursing homes are going
to be
just ravaged by coronavirus in all
likelihood and the fact is that if you
have a parent in a nursing home
that these places are just factories for
germs in many cases
i mean we've already known this with
regard to things like flu but when it
comes to coronavirus i mean there's this
nursing home
in in washington state and nearly all of
the deaths have been at this one nursing
home
if you have a bunch of elderly people in
close proximity to one another
in places where bodily fluids are being
spread then the chances
of disease are much much higher and
that's why those areas really should be
monitored
our society has really shuttled old
people more and more into nursing homes
and assisted living facilities
and you may see i i think over time as
as the danger of stuff like this becomes
apparent you may see more and more
people say i'd rather keep mom and dad
living in the guest bedroom and we'll
get to help them we'll get them the help
that they need at home which by the way
was sort of the model
of life for several thousand years up
until we started
basically paying a group of people to
take care of the elderly
in american society and abroad meanwhile
again
this none of this is to suggest that the
press has been responsible
on all this the press is not being
particularly responsible on all of this
they're sort of pushing an alarmist
an alarmist attitude toward all this
yesterday there were headlines
suggesting that president trump
had run out of the room when asked if he
had come down with coronavirus or if
he'd been tested with coronavirus that
was absolutely untrue reporters just
shouted it at him
first of all if you think the president
of the united states his health is not
being monitored you're out of your mind
he's the president of the united states
of course he probably has been tested
for coronavirus if he came in contact
with anyone who had it
but it is just indicative of the press
coverage the hysteria of the press
coverage that the headline that came out
of this little title
here was that president trump was
running away from questions as though
the top levels of the us government have
been infected
thank you very much
that is obviously not a situation where
he is running out of the room
nonetheless the media coverage was that
trump was running away from questions
about coronavirus which of course
is not true now meanwhile the economy
obviously has
seen itself really get hit hard
yesterday the s p 500 dropped more than
seven percent the dow dropped over two
thousand points almost eight percent
boeing apple goldman sachs caterpillar
cut the index by at least 100
points each the dell end of the day
below 24 000
the dow jones industrial average has
risen at least in early morning trading
above 24 000 but seems to be stagnating
right around 24 000 because nobody knows
exactly what is going to happen
originally the market self did trigger
that key market circuit breaker like 15
minutes in there's this new procedure
that basically
everybody pauses for 15 minutes to calm
their ass is down and then we move on
with the trading day that happened
yesterday it did seem to calm the market
a little bit the market dropped a little
bit from there but that was basically to
prohibit
a sort of follow-on effect that happened
in 2007-2008 when there are all sorts of
mechanisms in place that if the market
starts to drop precipitously there are
automated mechanisms
at a lot of companies or they will just
start selling stock because they're
afraid of stock market drop so they
actually caused the stock market drop
because of instant trading fears
also again worthwhile noting that the
market drop was not solely
about coronavirus a lot of it was about
saudi arabia and having and its ongoing
oil battles
with russia saudi arabia and the
russians were going to agree
to increase the output in order to
compete with u.s fracking and drive this
fracking into the ground
instead the russians decided not to do
that and the saudis were like okay well
we're just going to out-pump the
russians
also the saudis like hurting the
russians because the russians have been
supporting the syrians and the iranians
so there are all sorts of international
geopolitics issues
at play the double punch according to
cnbc sent crude careening to its worst
day since 1991.
now in terms of consumers that's
probably not a bad thing if you get
cheaper
gas at the pump that is not the end of
the world it's probably pretty good for
you
but in terms of the energy companies
obviously that is going to pound
their stock the economy is also facing
some serious headwinds because of the
global supply lines that are still
throughout china the fact is that we're
not going to know the economic impact
of coronavirus until china opens up its
factories again
right now china's factories still remain
largely closed so while coronavirus
diagnoses are going down the question is
how long are these factories going to
remain closed how long are those global
supply lines going to remain clogged up
before
the economy starts to flow fairly freely
again and this has led some people to
suggest well globalization was a bad
idea
well no globalization was a pretty good
idea the only question is
whether you really should have relied on
that factory in china alone what you're
not going to see
is return to autarky right we're going
to bring all the factories back to the
united states instead what you're going
to see
is duplicative factory capacity with
flexibility
in various areas of the globe so if
you're going to build a factory in china
you probably will also build the
capacity
to have a flexible factory someplace
else on planet earth in case china gets
hit
you're gonna see people create
duplicative supply lines in order so
that this sort of thing
does not happen again now does this
thing end in like a serious recession
i i honestly i doubt that it does i
doubt that we're going to end up in a
serious recession because of all this
because i think the coronavirus over the
next several months is going to mitigate
i think that people are going to
get this under control i think the
transmissions are going to drop i think
the number of cases are going to drop
we're already seeing in china we're
already seeing in south korea i would
not be surprised if by summer the
the viral spread of this has dropped
thanks in large part to people
taking more responsible action yes
washing your hands staying away from
other people
staying not shaking hands right all of
that will help
drop the spread if that happens people
will go back to work people will start
buying things again because they're
really not huge systemic
economic problems in the united states
there are in europe there are in china
but those problems have been
long-standing
you know the idea that the entire world
economy is going to fall into recession
simply because of coronavirus if this
thing only lasts three or four months
i don't think that that is likely to be
the case instead you'll probably get a
v-shaped recovery
nonetheless people are worried about all
of this
people are worried specifically about a
credit crunch that a lot of businesses
that are operating right at the margins
are going to go under that a lot of
businesses they can't afford to last
three or four months without significant
income are going to get hit we're going
to talk about all of that and the trump
administration's supposed response to
all of that we'll get to that
in just one second first let us talk
about the greatest underwear on planet
earth i
of course i'm talking about tommy john
underwear they grace this
fantastic but right now america's butt
they grace this butt
right now and let me tell you tommy john
underwear they're great for men they're
great for women my wife loves tommy
john's stuff tommy john is all about
fabric fit and function
tommy john obsesses over every little
detail and stitch by using proprietary
fabrics that perform
like nothing you have ever worn before
as a result tommy john's men's and
women's underwear supported no wedgie
guarantee
comfortable staple waistbands and a
range of fabrics that are luxuriously
soft featherlight moisture-wicking
breathable and designed to move with you
not against you that means no bunching
and no riding up tommy john is so
confident in their underwear that if you
don't love your first pair you can get a
full refund with their best pair you'll
ever wear or it's free guarantee
you can also find them in over 1200
retail locations across the country
including nordstrom stores nationwide
tommy john no adjustment
needed the right pair of underwear it's
kind of a big deal since you're going to
be living in them basically 24 hours a
day
hurry to tommyjohn.com ben for 20 off
your first order that is tommyjohn.com
ben for 20 off have the best underwear
on the market they really are durable as
well
tommyjohn.com go check them out right
now tommyjohn.com
okay so what are the underlying economic
issues
well again you have the the european
governments that have been
basically been having stagnant growth
rates for a decade or more you've had
china which has been wildly
overestimating its growth rates for a
very long time
based on debt-led growth in the united
states we've been spending out the wazoo
right these debt issues eventually
are going to come due because what
exactly is the appetite for more debt if
it appears that we're never going to pay
it off
with all of that said if this thing
if this thing were to mitigate in fairly
short order then you will see a v-shaped
recovery and it will not be an issue
by the time of the election you're
starting to see the trump administration
talk about what government measures they
are looking at some of these are a good
idea some of these are a bad idea
some of the good ideas for example
barack obama did this in 2011 2012 would
be a brief
payroll tax holiday meaning you get to
delay paying your taxes on a quarterly
basis if you're a small company
this makes a lot of sense because the
government doesn't need to suck up more
of your taxpayer dollars they actually
need your dollars
to go to your employees you need to
continue paying your employees so
they're saying you're still going to
have to pay taxes on the back end but
we're going to take a payroll tax
holiday for the moment
that is a good idea for example anything
that lowers taxes in this
in the face of this is a good idea so we
can continue paying our employees for
example
anything that is a specific subsidy to
specific industries
that is a bad idea the reason that's a
bad idea is because it is now
suggesting that some industries are more
important than other industries which is
not true
it is it is creating a perverse
incentive for
industries to operate right at the
margin right at the margin so if they
take a real hit then all of a sudden
they're looking to the government for a
bailout and that's not how you want to
run a business you want to run a
business
in both a risk-seeking fashion where it
is appropriate but also a risk-averse
fashion in terms of making sure that
your business remains profitable
creating incentive structures where
businesses are right on the verge of
going under every other minute and then
they look to the taxpayer to bail them
out is a real mistake it's a real
mistake so president trump yesterday did
a press conference he laid out some of
the government measures that were
possibly on the table here was the
president of the united states yesterday
we're going to be meeting with house
republicans mitch mcconnell everybody
and discussing a possible
payroll tax uh cut or relief
substantial relief very substantial
relief that's a big
that's a big number uh we're also going
to be talking about hourly
wage earners getting help
working with companies and small
companies large companies a lot of
companies
so that they don't get penalized for
something that's not their fault it's
not
their fault it's not our country's fault
okay so
some of these ideas are fairly good i
don't know what that hourly wage
policy that he's talking about actually
looks like is he just talking about
again
delaying taxes on companies that the
companies can afford to pay their hourly
wage earners if so again i don't see
that as a huge problem
if we are talking about the government
stepping in and basically increasing
unemployment
even that is not necessarily the end of
the world for the moment but
that's not like i'm not clear on exactly
what the policy is hopefully we'll see
some details and then we'll know where
we stand
on all of it he said he was seeking to
provide assistance this is the part
where i start to get a little uptight
the president also said he was seeking
to provide assistance to the airline
hotel and cruise industries which are
all suffering as americans rapidly
cancelled travel plans
and the answer on that is no okay first
of all we shouldn't be helping the
cruise industry they're all foreign
flagged anyway
like it doesn't make any sense for us to
be bailing out cruises that are flagged
in in norway
why exactly are we bailing out cruise
industries i understand they are
disproportionately elderly i understand
that elderly people don't want to be on
cruises right
now i get all of that but we shouldn't
be bailing out the cruise industry
thanks to coronavirus as far as the
travel industry
i'll tell you right now is a great time
to buy airline tickets i'll tell you
that
and by the way the airline tickets they
are priced down and out
meaning that if you buy tickets like
seven months from now then now is a
great time to buy those tickets
and i'll be honest i just bought some
airline tickets yesterday i mean i
looked at the prices
and i was thinking okay where do i want
to go on vacation with my family later
this year
assuming the coronavirus lets up which
in all likelihood it will
the prices are going down right i mean
the market is taking an effect prices
are going down and that means some
buying opportunities for people by the
way
this is also true in the stock market
you saw a lot of headlines yesterday
about investors losing
billions and billions and trillions of
dollars yesterday because of the stock
market dropping
if you're a smart investor i'll tell you
how much money you lost yesterday big
old zero the reason you lost big old
zero yesterday and maybe you made money
is because if you are a major investor
you did not sell your stocks yesterday
it is probably marginal investors who
largely sold their stocks it is not
major investors who are like warren
buffett was not sitting around yesterday
going oh no the stock market's dropping
i'm selling all of my stocks for less
than i paid for them
i remember buffett once got asked about
2007 2008 how much money he lost said i
didn't lose a dime i didn't sell
anything
it's like when the real estate market
goes down if you own a house did you
just lose money
when the real estate market went down if
you didn't sell your house the answer is
no you didn't lose any money because you
didn't sell your house
right the price is independent of you
actually realizing the price in the open
market
now it's unclear based on president
trump's comments whether he's going to
ask congress to help these industries or
if he thinks he can do it
on his own but again bailouts are a bad
idea i thought they were a bad idea in
2007 2008 they do create moral hazard
in certain crisis situations and there's
a case to be made that the bailout of
the banks was simply necessary in 2008
because all of these banks were already
government dependent and because they're
already government dependent
and because the the risk had already
been diffused throughout the economy
thanks to government malfeasance over
the past decade and a half
that the government basically had to
step in at that point to prevent
complete collapse
but that is just because the government
intervened too much in the first place
the fact is if you are in the in the
airline industry
and you are taking a hit well them is
the consequences of living in a real
world where sometimes demand goes up and
sometimes demand goes down the same
thing is true of hotels
and if by the way these businesses were
operating at the margins if these
businesses
were operating in irresponsible fashion
in the sense that they're going to go
bankrupt if they are not bailed out
guess what i promise you there are
plenty of people who are willing to buy
hotel chains
and are willing to invest in hotel
chains and buy a share and reinfuse with
cash
on the assumption that corona virus is
going to let up in six months
so bailouts this is one of the great
misnomers about bailouts is that
bailouts prevent companies
from going completely defunct when the
auto companies were bailed out the
choice was not between those auto
companies being bailed out and the auto
companies simply not existing anymore
the choices between the auto companies
being bailed out and investors coming in
and buying the auto companies and
treating them in a different way
right chapter seven bankruptcy when a
company goes bankrupt that does not mean
that the company closes its doors
it just means they have to sell off
their assets in order to pay off debtors
and it also means that somebody comes in
and picks up the company
and somebody new comes in and invests in
the company so
bailouts are not the answer to this
particular problem
a payroll tax holiday is a different
sort of thing because that is just the
government saying we're not going to
that is the government
taking its its boot off your throat that
is not the government actively injecting
you with steroids
so there's a big difference in kind
between those two things
okay in just a second we're gonna get to
chuck schumer who's ripping on trump and
we'll get to the politics of all of this
in just one second first the daily wires
on andrew clavin has released the second
entry and has another kingdom trilogy
the nightmare feast
austin lively once just an out of luck
hollywood screenwriter is now a chosen
hero
caught between two worlds and dual
quests in both los angeles and the
magical medieval world of galliana
experience the fantasy adventure that
captivated and entertained
thousands of listeners despite michael
knowles being the starring voice you've
heard the podcast now get the book today
over at amazon go check it out drew's a
great writer time meanwhile is running
out to get 25
off all daily wire memberships with
coupon code never socialist so hurry
before the deal ends just like the
bernie sanders campaign which as we'll
discuss shortly
is about to meet its well-deserved doom
daily wire members get an ad free
website experience access to all of our
live broadcasts and show library
the full three hours of the ben shapiro
show access to the mailbag and now
exclusive election insight op-eds from
yours truly
daily wire members also get to ask us
questions during backstage our new
all-access tier allows you to join in
live online q a's with me
and the other hosts as well along with
all of this of course you get the
magnificent the irreplaceable the
singular leftist years tumblr if you
haven't already
download the daily wear app you can get
all of our great content on the go again
that is 25
off on dailywire memberships for all
plans using coupon code and never
socialist so
head on over to dailywear.com subscribe
this is the last week we'll be giving
you this offer
so act now before you regret it and you
will that's dailywire.com
subscribe we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
now again the democrats are trying to
make hay out of all of this they're
suggesting that trump has completely
botched the response
again trump's public attitude toward all
of this
has not been wonderful i mean you don't
want him tweeting you don't want him
i talked about this yesterday he really
should be quiet and let his experts talk
his experts know what they are talking
about but the generalized perception
that the trump administration has blown
it
that obviously is not true chuck schumer
is trying to promote that idea of course
because
the opposition party always tries to
make it seem that the party in power is
blowing it when it comes to public
crises here's chuck schumer trying to
call trump's response slip shot
the federal government's initial
response to the coronavirus was slipshod
at best it has greatly hurt the country
and it falls at the feet of the
president the buck
stops with him now i know president
trump will dismiss these criticisms and
accuse democrats of playing politics
that's what he always does when there's
legitimate criticism
because in president trump's world
there's no such thing as a legitimate
criticism of his administration
okay that that is not having much impact
now here's the deal everybody is sort of
assuming
that the coronavirus stuff could really
hurt trump the more trump talks about it
the more it hurts him but
all in all the approval of his actions
is exactly equal to his approval rating
in other words everything seems to be
priced into trump like literally all the
things seem to be priced in with
president trump a new poll from
quinnipiac shows president approval's
overall approval rating at 54
disapproved to 41 to prove the poll
finds that 53
have confidence in the fed's
responsibility to handle the response
the federal government's
ability to handle the response only 43
do not
as far as trump 43 percent of voters
approve of his handling of coronavirus
don't which looks exactly exactly like
his approval rating
87 percent of republicans approve of
jobs trump's job performance 83
of democrats disapprove half of
independence disapprove so
basically everything is is already baked
in
with regard to president trump by the
way there are polls showing that
congressional republicans are more
popular than congressional democrats
right now
so it seems like the voter poll the
voter polarization
that has hit the country so hard is not
waning in the aftermath of corona virus
it was an opportunity for trump to do
better
but he didn't and he's not also he's not
doing worse he's not dropping
precipitously in the polls
so far as we can see for now meanwhile
today is a big primary day for the
democrats so it is a
it is the the end of the road presumably
for bernie sanders
there are several primaries today and
these primaries
do not look good for bernie i mean
they're sort of a disaster for bernie
this is particularly true
in in michigan in michigan he is just
getting skunked so remember
he won michigan in sort of a shock last
time around
people expected hillary clinton to do
really well in michigan that of course
did not materialize
the last poll had her up he ended up
winning michigan bernie did by about 25
points
he's not going to win michigan today
he's going to get skunked in michigan
so according to the latest real club
politics poll averages
michigan biden is leading sanders by 22
points 22 points
in missouri biden is leading sanders by
30.3 points
30 points so so biden is going to finish
bernie off today and that will be the
end
of bernie sanders meanwhile
yeah so some of the further states like
florida are really really looking bad
for bernie sanders so bernie is
desperately
trying to regain momentum but he
basically has nothing
it's important to remember guys that the
bernie sanders popularity in 2016 was
largely based on running against hillary
clinton it turns out the best thing you
can ever do is run against hillary
clinton with the exception of rick lazio
every other politician who has ever run
against hillary clinton barack obama
the the barack obama bernie sanders
donald trump every politician who has
ever run against hillary clinton has
done really well
people do not like hillary clinton i
mean here's a good indicator of that
bernie sanders yesterday did a town hall
on fox news
and he's asked about hillary clinton and
the crowd boos hillary because people
just hate hillary clinton i mean there's
just no two ways about it
he was a career politician he had he did
not work till he was like 41 and then he
got elected to something
it was all just baloney and i feel so
bad that you know people got
sucked into it wow that strong stuff
what's your reaction
[Applause]
unlike secretary clinton i don't want to
relive 2016. we're in 2020.
so half of bernie's popularity was based
on the fact that people hated
hillary clinton now that bernie is seen
in a vacuum people are not super fond of
bernie and there's a reason for that
that's because
bernie is awful he's truly awful now
bernie is
starting to burn bernie is still shying
away from a couple of the attack lines
on joe biden that might actually be
telling
like he said yesterday he won't question
joe biden's mental fitness well good
luck
with that but it's the fact that that
people are finally examining bernie
sanders agenda that is sending him
to the to the political graveyard here
and the fact is
that bernie was leading up until the
point he became the frontrunner and then
as soon as he became the front runner
sort of like elizabeth warren people
started examining him and they're like
well
well and there's a reason for that last
night on fox news bernie admits yeah you
know there's gonna be a giant price tag
to all the programs that i'm proposing
how can you pay for all this good all
right
now i don't have the teleprompter all
right but i'll do my best all right
i was to get the numbers right okay good
question all right let's deal with it
fair question bernie you're proposing
bold ideas how are you going to pay for
him right
with a big price tag yes all right let's
deal with him okay and then he never
deals with them
what he means by a big price tag is like
giant giant price tags one of the best
moments of his fox news
his fox news spiel last night is bernie
was talking about socialism and he says
well people keep talking about socialism
like socialism is cuba
or like it's the soviet union but it's
not it's sweden and then he is hit with
the fact that sweden is not in fact
socialist and has nothing to say
here is jo here's bernie sanders being
completely disarmed on national tv
i'm talking about finland i'm talking
about
denmark i'm talking about sweden i'm
talking about countries all over the
world who have used their government
to try to improve life for working
families not just the people on top
if you look at examples in sweden and
denmark
they have been lowering or cutting
property taxes
lowering corporate taxes allowing
vouchers for schools for public schools
so they appear to be moving
away more towards market reform and not
towards what you're describing you'd
like to see here
and bernie's like well i don't know
about that
one of one of the most hilarious things
about bernie sanders is socialism is
that he picks a bunch of capitalist
countries and then says how wonderful
their socialism is
by the way all the talk about the trump
administration mishandling coronavirus
it is largely focused on trump's
rhetoric for a reason and the reason
that people are largely focused on
trump's rhetoric with regard to
coronavirus
is specifically because if they focused
on his action the democrats have nothing
better in fact bernie sanders program he
says i should be the head of the
government because i'd handle
coronavirus better and then he proceeds
to say one of the dumbest things in
human history
about coronavirus and how to fight it he
says he would not close borders in the
face of coronavirus
which is a genius move just every other
country in europe is doing it if an
entire travel shutdown in italy you have
an entire travel shutdown in israel
you're seeing every major country in
europe
closing its borders to people who are
not tested and bernie's like no i would
allow everyone to travel in first of all
i mean is bernie aware of his age and
health condition like bernie is on the
hit list for coronavirus right bernie
checks every single box for
vulnerability to coronavirus he does
i mean older people are really really
vulnerable to this thing
bernie's i i'll say this for the man i
mean his ideological purism apparently
has no bounds here's bernie saying he
wouldn't shut borders in the face of
coronavirus
if you had to would you close down the
borders
no i mean what you don't want to do
right now we have a president
who has propagated xenophobic
anti-immigrant sentiment from before he
was elected
what we need to do is have the
scientists
take a hard look at what we need to do
there are communities where the virus is
spreading
what does that mean it may mean
self-quarantining it may be
not having public assemblies uh but
let's not
go back to the same old thing yeah the
premise of the question bernie was if
you need to shut the borders will you do
it and you started off by saying no
so i i think that this sort of undercuts
your credibility also you do have to
love bernie sanders shouting that
coronavirus vaccine should be free for
all
he promises absolutely free chronovirus
vaccine inflected how does he think the
coronavirus vaccine is going to be
developed it will be developed by
private pharmaceutical companies in all
likelihood who then charge either the us
government
or or actual individual consumers or
health insurance why does he want to
unburden health insurance companies by
the way
i keep hearing that health insurance
companies are the worst thing in the
world
why wouldn't he why wouldn't he force
health insurance companies to cover
coronavirus vaccine he apparently just
thinks things get created
out of thin air without any profit
margin attached to them that people sit
around in their basement and for fun
create coronavirus vaccines that is not
the way the economy works bernie sanders
being a complete fool
trump's people were saying just a little
while ago that yeah we're working on a
vaccine
hopefully they are but
but this is how crazy it is
we couldn't guarantee that when that
vaccine is developed
they couldn't guarantee that people
would be able to afford it
i mean this is how sick this system
is so let me tell you if elected
president
everybody in this country will get that
vaccine absolutely free
is that a radical statement okay first
of all
flu vaccine costs like 25 bucks a pop it
costs like 25 bucks a pop
i'm fairly certain that health insurance
covers things like flu vaccine for the
vast majority of americans i am sure
that medicaid
covers flu vaccine for people the notion
that people are going to go unvaccinated
is simply ridiculous all the way
throughout but that is that is bernie
sanders campaign
and the good news is it's basically over
today which which is great
because his campaign is so radical that
he had an imam open his rally yesterday
that imam has declared
that the jews are basically the worst
people on planet earth they said
he actually suggested that the jews
created isis
that guy opened bernie sanders rally
yesterday that imam he had also
suggested that bernie is trustworthy
even quote even though he is a jew
which is always a great way to to term
that sort of thing meanwhile joe biden
continues to stumble around the country
again his big picture is that he is not
trump so yesterday he was on msnbc
and he says about coronavirus i wish
that trump would just be quiet this is
the area where biden is going to do
fairly well if he can make trump's
chaos and sort of volatility the issue
then biden does well the problem
for biden is that biden actually is kind
of chaotic and volatile himself as we'll
talk about in just a second
here's biden attacking trump over
coronavirus
there's no confidence in the president
and anything he says or does
he turns everything into what he thinks
is a political benefit for himself and
he's actually
imploding in the process but there's a
lot of innocent bystanders that are
being
badly hurt and i i just think it i mean
i wish he would just be quiet i
really mean it i'm not a special reason
awful thing to say about a president
would you be quiet
just let the experts speak and
acknowledge whatever they suggest to him
is what we should be doing okay there's
only one problem with all of this for
joe biden and that is that joe biden is
not the world's most stable dude either
okay joe biden is not captain stability
first of all man cannot string a
sentence together i mean truly cannot
string a sentence together
he he is well people are now attempting
to suggest that it is somehow ages to
point this out it is not aegis
people are suggesting that that biden's
lack of verbal cogency and coherence at
this point
is due to the fact that he has overcome
stuttering which is an amazing
achievement it really is
it's amazing that joe biden overcame
stuttering this has nothing to do with
his stuttering okay
i've been watching joe biden for years
when he was vice president the stuff he
is doing now is not a result
of stuttering the stuff that he is doing
now is a result of the fact that he's in
cognitive decline
i think it is very obvious to everybody
who's been watching joe biden he's not
the same person that he was eight years
ago and that is not a rip
on joe biden as a human being that is a
fact of life as you age
once you get beyond a certain age the
possibility of cognitive decline is
certainly on the table
and it's weird to me that all the same
people who are suggesting that john
mccain was in cognitive decline
when he was running for president and
who's significantly younger than biden
in 2008
are now like oh well don't talk about
joe biden don't talk about joe biden's
age don't talk about his inability
to to speak clearly it also happens to
be true that joe biden
is a volatile dude himself today joe
biden was speaking to blue-collar union
workers in michigan
and they were asking him about guns and
he just started shouting at them
like really shouting at them like these
are these are his prospective voters
he called some of them full of bleep he
told them to shush
he told them they don't need an ar-14
which is not an actual
gun that means ar 15 that he's looking
for he told somebody don't be a horse's
ass
he said an ar is a machine gun which it
is not he said
i'm not working for you they're voters
so that's that's sort of confusing
so as the campaign goes on and we see
more of joe biden his campaign no pun
intended is not going to age
particularly well okay time for a quick
thing i like and then we'll get to a
quick thing
that i hate so things that i like today
i may as well mention it since everybody
is apparently watching it
the steven soderbergh film contagion is
in fact a very good film it is a film
about
what would happen if there were to be
corona divers but actually as deadly as
people
seem to panic that coronavirus is if
sars for example
with a 10 death rate had been or or
rather
mirrors with a 10 death rate uh if those
no sorrows had ten percent out right if
stars with the 10 death rate
had hit millions or billions of people
instead of hitting a very tiny fraction
of the population
here's a little bit of the preview for
contagion which actually is a very well
researched film in terms of how the
federal government would respond
to the possibility of something like
this
what's this it's transmission so we just
need to know which direction
on day one there were two people and
then four
and then sixteen in three months it's a
billion that's where we're heading
they're calling out the national guard
they're moving the president underground
people will panic
get away it will tip over the truth is
being kept from the world
cook your samples destroy everything
hello i need you to get me the names of
everyone who serves this room
it's an emergency there there's a
there's a reason why this film is is
doing so well right now in terms of
people renting it and that's because
people are freaking out
and this is exactly what's going on and
again the depiction is actually fairly
accurate this was
it was commented on at the time how well
researched this whole thing was
is this that no it is not it is not okay
so just know that contagion is not what
is actually happening on planet earth
right now we've had a grand total of
like 4 000 people dead across the entire
planet we've had 100 000 infections
not a billion infections but that's why
people are worried so
if you if you want to watch a super
creepy movie that'll scare the living
crap out of you in the middle of a panic
then absolutely go check out contagion
otherwise maybe avoid contagion until
everybody is done with their panic
okay time for a couple of quick things
that i hate
so i am deeply pleased deeply pleased
that bernie sanders campaign will come
to an
glorious end today as i've said before i
think it is very good for the country
that that bernie that bernie sanders is
not going to be the democratic nominee
having half the american population
rally around an old communist who hangs
out with people
who hate the country and also happen to
hate allies like israel
it's a very good thing we avoided that
fate it is and i think that donald trump
is in
fairly good position against joe biden
in all the latest polls he's running
even with him in all of those
battleground states which is kind of
where he has to be
okay but the fact is that bernie sanders
has surrounded himself with the worst
people in american politics
one of those people of course is
representative versus talib who keeps
insisting she's not an anti-semite
even while wearing a shirt that
literally erases
israel from existing there's a picture
of her holding up linda sarsour's
new book okay linda sarsour is an awful
anti-semite in her own right
she has stood with actual anti-semitic
terrorists rashida talib took a picture
of herself holding up
linda sarsour's new book because their
besties and she's also wearing a shirt
that has a picture of the entire land of
israel with palestinian symbols over it
so when she suggests that she is in
favor of quote unquote one state
solution right this is what she said
she's not in favor of a two-state
solution
she wants a one-state solution that sure
makes it fairly obvious exactly what
kind of one-state solution she is
looking for
namely she's looking for a one-state
solution where
the muslim arabs run things and the jews
don't exist i mean that is what the
shirt is the shirt literally has over
there there's no separation between the
west bank and gaza strip this is why
when people suggest
why doesn't israel just make territorial
deals with the palestinian authority
and with hamas and hezbollah and with
all of these various entities well
the answer is because those people want
to kill them they want to destroy them
rashidatali would love to see the
israeli
state wiped completely off the face of
the earth there's an online
advertisement for the shirt
according to the free beacon stand in
solidarity with palestine by wearing
this beautiful palestine t-shirt an
outline map of palestine is filled with
red white and green arabic letters that
look stunning from a distance and spell
the word palestine up close
a pattern shamach wraps around the neck
of the palestinian state like the brave
soldiers whose boots stand on the dusty
ground
those brave soldiers presumably many of
those would be terrorists so just
what a wonderful what wonderful people
bernie surrounds himself with
really are a joy by the way just to note
the people that bernie sanders and
rashida to leave have sympathy for are
the same sorts of people
who literally have been sending party
balloons bearing bombs into israel
this is the thing the washington repo
post reported yesterday
from niti vote israel the moment mehrab
hani's daughter stopped loving
kindergarten came when a cluster of
colorful orbs floated toward her
playground during recess balloons had a
please young emma her mother recalled
but another child wanted her warnings
from local police knew better that's a
bomb
in recent months hundreds of booby-trap
balloons sometimes burying the messages
i love you and happy birthday
along with small ieds dangling by a
string
have descended on this or other
communities downwind of the nearby gaza
strip according to israeli police
they're not seeking to kill israeli
soldiers they're not seeking to do
military damage they're seeking to kill
children
when you set balloons that's a happy
birthday on them
into populated areas with bombs
connected to them
can you think of anything really more
evil than that it's hard to think of
things that are more evil than that
really
most of these are landing in open
countryside none has just caused injury
or death
residents know the balloons are not as
dangerous as the rockets fired by
militant groups in gaza that be
terrorist groups
still the escalation of this drifting
menace has taxed police departments
disrupted daily life and taken a
psychological toll who live
within reach of the gaza breeze the
purpose of course is to kill children
that is the goal of these things but
don't worry there's a peace deal to be
made and it's
only israel it's only jewish
intransigence that is causing all this
probably israel should just open its
borders
probably israel just let all the people
who are floating balloons with ieds
cross the border or at least let in
groups of people without any sort of
screening so those people can just enter
israel makes perfect sense to me
these are the people that bernie sanders
has sympathy for these are the people
that recited talib has sympathy
for now i would be remiss if i did not
note at this point that it is the
jewish holiday of purim today purim is a
fantastic holiday it's a really
interesting holiday
it's the it's the holiday where jews
read the magilla the magilla is a story
of a an anti-semitic regime that seeks
to wipe the jews off the face of the
planet
and is thwarted only by the decisive
action of queen esther who is a jew
who's roped into marriage
to the king of persia is how the basic
story goes and her uncle whose advisor
to the king
mordechai stops another advisor haman
from carrying out
this genocidal wave of hatred against
the jews
and the reason that purim remains a
relevant holiday is because the name of
god is not mentioned anywhere anywhere
in the miguel
it's really interesting i mean it's a
religious text the name of god is not
mentioned anywhere in the entire magilla
the reason being it is the most modern
of all of the
the jewish texts in terms of its content
meaning it basically suggests
that anti-semitism is only thwarted on a
realistic level in today's world
by the concerted action of politically
oriented people who understand true
threats and who are not going to be put
off by lies
so the fact that that we read the
magilla every year is a reminder that
genocidal anti-semitism still exists it
exists in the gaza strip it exists in
iran it exists in the west bank it
exists in southern lebanon
and that anybody who refuses to
acknowledge that is going to have to be
convinced on a political level
of the reality of that situation okay
because people tend to believe that
evil anti-semitism is only a figment of
the pastor that anti-semitism only
exists when it's in
an a-hole waving a nazi flag at a bernie
sanders rally
but the fact is anti-semitism is very
alive it is very well and genocidal
anti-semitism is overlooked
by large swaths of the west particularly
the highest levels of politics
we need to remember that because bernie
sanders who
has been called a victim of
anti-semitism which on a broad level is
ridiculous
bernie sanders is a propagator of
anti-semitism i'm very very glad to see
bernie sanders campaign
end today it is well deserved and
hopefully he goes back to the earned
obscurity
that he is that he so richly deserves
over the course of 80
useless years on planet earth worse than
useless counterproductive years
on planet earth alrighty we'll be here a
little bit later today with all of your
updates and then we'll be back here
tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas directed by mike joyner
executive producer jeremy boring
supervising producer mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pablo wydowski
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by nick
sheehan associate producer katie
swinerton
edited by adam syavet audio is mixed by
mike coromina
hair and makeup is by nika geneva the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
democrats in six states head to the
primaries today and polling shows biden
might blow
bernie out of the water within just a
matter of hours we will examine the
latest data on joe's chances in november
then pundits on all sides attack the
president for his response to the flu
manchu outbreak
but a very important group much more
important than the chattering class
thinks president trump is doing just
fine
finally a woman asks slate if she should
tell her husband to stop sleeping with
his girlfriend
to stop coronavirus from spreading to
her mother we will break down this
woman's problems our culture's problems
both biological and social all that and
more check it out on the michael knowles
show
you